ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS EIGHTY
BAKER FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTES E. DALLY DODD
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO- TADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA LIMON
MMHM MCGUIRE MELENDEZ NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TELEPHONE PAN
PORTANTINO. RALPH RUBIO SKINNER
NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR RUBIO AFTER WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
SPECTER. THANK YOU. GOD OF
HEALING AND HOPE MAY YOUR LOVE
AND COMPASSION ABOUND AS WE
ENTER THE CONTINUING CHALLENGE
OF THE CORONA VIRUS AND
EXPERIENCE WE ASK FOR WISDOM FOR
THOSE WHO BEAR THE LOAD OF
MAKING DECISIONS WITH WIDESPREAD
CONSEQUENCES WE PAY FOR THOSE
SUFFERING FROM SICKNESS AND ALL
WHO ARE CARING FOR THEM WE PAY
FOR FREEDOM FROM PARALYZING FEAR
AND ANXIETY AND AT THE SAME TIME
MAY WE EXERCISE COMMON SENSE FOR
THE GOOD OF THE WHOLE. THROUGH
THIS TIME OF GLOBAL CONCERN MAY
YOUR SPIRIT BRING OUT THE BEST
IN US MAKEUPS MORE AWARE ARBOR
INTERDEPENDENCE ON EACH OTHER
HELP US APPROACH EACH DAY IN
PHASE AND PLEASE TRUSTING IN THE
TWO OF US TOWARDS US AND
DEEPENING OUR COMPASSIONATE
CONNECTION WITH THOSE WHO ARE
MOST VULNERABLE WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME. AMEN. WHICH STATED
SENATOR BAKER BUT HE IS NOT HERE
TO OUR WAREHOUSE. GENERAL THE
LEADERS AND FOOT.
MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE SENATORS DRAWS ALL MEN
AND STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE MOVING
TO THE PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SURE LEARN ARE YOU PREPARED.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT ARM. IT
IS BOTH AN HONOR AND WITH A
LITTLE SADNESS THAT I RISE TODAY
TO HONOR A MY FRIEND AND A GREAT
STATE SERVANT ELAINE HOWELL
WHO'S DEDICATED HER ENTIRE
CAREER TO SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
THIS STATE THROUGH THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS OF SERVICE AND SHE IS IN
THE GALLERY AND WILL EVENTUALLY
BE GETTING OUR RESOLUTION UP
THERE. AS IS THE PRACTICE. SHE
BEGAN HER CAREER AS AN ENTRY
LEVEL PERFORMANCE AUDITOR AT THE
OFFICE OF THE AUDITOR GENERAL
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU
DAN ASCENDED TO VARIOUS
POSITIONS IN THE ORGANIZATION
AND ITS SUCCESSOR ORGANIZATION
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. IN AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
SHE WAS APPOINTED AS
CALIFORNIA'S STATE AUDITOR.
BECOMING THE FIRST FEMALE AND
EVENTUALLY THE LONGEST SERVING.
INDEPENDENT STATE AUDITOR HE WAS
REAPPOINTED FOUR MORE TIMES TO
THE POSITION BY THREE DIFFERENT
GOVERNORS. ARE KNOWN FOR HER
PASSION AND HER EXPERTISE HER
TAKE GRITTI. AND SPEAKING TRUTH
TO POWER. SHE'S BEEN A VALUABLE
RESOURCE TO THIS LEGISLATURE AND
A STRONG AND TRUSTED VOICE. HE'S
ALSO HELD NUMEROUS POSITIONS
WITH VARIOUS ASSOCIATIONS MOST
NOTABLY AS PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF STATE
AUDITORS CONTROLLERS AND
TREASURERS AND THE NATIONAL
STATE AUDITORS ASSOCIATION.
ANYWHERE ANYONE THAT KNOWS HER
KNOWS HER PASSION AND LOVE FOR
SPORTS ESPECIALLY BASEBALL SHE'S
A DIE HARD BOSTON RED SOX FAN
WHICH A FEW PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR
WILL FORGIVE HER. SHE'S ALSO A
LONGTIME SOFTBALL PLAYER THEN I
DISCOVERED IN THE COURSE OF
DOING THIS RESOLUTION SHE
ACTUALLY FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
PLAYED PROFESSIONAL SOFTBALL IN
A PROFESSIONAL LEAGUE ALONG THE
WAY. HER UNWAVERING COMMITMENT
EXTENDS BEYOND HER PROFESSIONAL
CAREER. A SHOOTER WIFE CINDY
HAVE A HUMBLE BUT GENEROUS AND
GIVING SPIRIT TOWARD THEIR
FAMILY FRIENDS COWORKERS AND
MANY CAUSES. UPON HER RETIREMENT
TO BE ABLE TO ENJOY SOME NEEDED
TIME OFF WITH CINDY TO TRAVEL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. WITH THEIR
DOGS MATTIE AND CHARLIE AND
CONTINUED TO KEEP A WATCHFUL EYE
ON THE GOOD WORK OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE. AND I CAN JUST
SAY PERSONALLY AS SOMEONE. OUR
WHO. CHAIRED THE AUDIT COMMITTEE
FOR A WHILE WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WAS AUDITED BY THE
AUDITOR WHEN I WAS A CABINET
SECRETARY AND THE VICE CHAIR NOW
OF THE AUDIT COMMITTEE SHE HAS
BEEN DILIGENT SHE HAS BEEN FAIR
SHE HAS BEEN ON POINT SHE HAS
BEEN NONPARTISAN AND GOD HELP
THE PERSON THAT SUCCEEDS HER FOR
HAVING TO LIVE UP TO THE
STANDARD THAT SHE HAS SET. I
KNOW THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE THAT
WISH TO TALK AND WE ARE
PRESENTING THE RESOLUTION I TO
HER UP IN THE GALLERY BUT AT
LEAST AT THE BEGINNING PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THANKING- THE HARDER
LINE HALL FOR HER SERVICE.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS- I DO
WANT TO- RISE AND GIVE PROPER
HONOR TO ARE RETIRING STATE
AUDITOR MS HOWELL I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE ON THE
JOINT AUDIT COMMITTEE WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND TRULY ONE OF
THE BRIGHT SPOTS OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNANCE IS THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND THAT IS ONLY BECAUSE
IT'S LED BY MS HOW AND- CENTER
LAYERED SAID RIGHTFULLY IT'S
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT FOR
ANYBODY TO COME INTO THIS
POSITION AND LIVE UP TO THE
STANDARD THAT SHE HAS SET. AS A
STATE AUDITOR- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I RECOGNIZE AND- I
THINK A LOT OF US IN OUR
CONSTITUENTS RECOGNIZE THAT.
MANY OF THE- GOOD POINTS OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNANCE- IS
BECAUSE OF THE OVERSIGHT. THAT
THE AUDITOR HAS BROUGHT TO BEAR.
OVER HER TIME AS IS AS A STATE
AUDITOR AND THE IMPROVEMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE IN THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS IN THE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF STATE GOVERNMENT. AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- THAT ISSUES
LOOKED INTO AS WELL. ARE BECAUSE
OF THE HONEST. AND FORTHRIGHT
AND- CLEAR DIRECTION AND- PUT
THINGS THAT SHE HAS POINTED OUT
IN THESE AUDITS AND I MENTIONED-
LAST YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE THE
NEW GRAPHICS THAT THEY'RE USING
IN THEIR REPORTS ARE INCREDIBLE-
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THAT
BRINGS TO LIGHT AND MAKES IT
EASY TO DIGEST SOME OF THESE
REPORTS THAT ARE YOU KNOW VERY
DETAIL ORIENTED- BUT I JUST WANT
TO SAY PERSONALLY MISS HEALTH
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN AN HONOR AND
A PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH YOU YOU
ARE A CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL.
AND THE LOSERS TODAY ARE THE
RESIDENTS AND TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR LONG YOUR LONG
TIME A SERVICE TO OUR STATE WE
REALLY DO- YOU IN HONOR OF DEBT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
JOHN SENATOR NELSON. MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE. I TOO WOULD LIKE
TO SING THE PRAISES OF HONOR HOW
. AND I'VE BEEN THROUGH MANY
AUDITORS. INTEGRITY INDEED IS
THE CHARACTER OF THIS OFFICE.
AND PARTICULARLY THIS ORDER. THE
LATEST DONE A MARVELOUS JOB OVER
THE YEARS WITH THE THOROUGHNESS
THE CREDIBILITY AND THE TRUST
AND TRUST IS SO IMPORTANT IN THE
POSITION THAT SHE HOPED. ELAINE
EVEN LEAD TO RENAISSANCE LIFE.
I'M SURE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO LIVE THAT
RENAISSANCE LIFE. WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE STATE LEGISLATORS TO SELL
RELY UPON YOU GODSPEED. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT IN DECEMBER OF THIS
YEAR I WILL HAVE COMPLETED TEN
YEARS ON THE- ON THE RED CARPET.
I DISTINCTLY REMEMBER WALKING
OUT OF THIS BUILDING THAT FIRST
WEEK OF DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE AND- TELLING MY POLITICAL
TEAM. HOW FRIENDLY EVERYONE IN
SACRAMENTO WAS AT WHICH POINT
THEY LAUGHED AT ME. AND THEY
PROBABLY TOLD ME THE SAME THING
THAT OTHER FOLKS HAVE TOLD YOU.
SENATOR IF YOU WANT A FRIEND TO
GO GET A DOG. FIRSTLY I DIDN'T
FIND THAT TO BE TRUE NOT IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND CERTAINLY NOT
IN THIS CHAMBER. AND NOT WITH MY
FRIEND OUR STATE AUDITOR. ELAINE
HOWLE. THE FIRST MEADOW LANE
WHEN I WAS ASSIGNED. AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE IN ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. AND OVER THE
NEXT SIX YEARS DURING MY TOUR IS
VICE HERE ARE THE DISTINCT
PLEASURE. WATCHING OUR STATE
AUDITOR IN ACTION. I CAN
HONESTLY SAY THAT IN ALL OF MY
JOBS. IN THE MILITARY IN
BUSINESS. IN LIVE NEVER HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH THE
PERSON MORE FOCUSED MORE HARD
WORKING MORE PROFESSIONAL MORE
PUBLIC SERVICE MINDED. AND MORE
COURAGEOUS. THEN ELAINE HELL.
SHE COULD CERTAINLY TALK TRUTH
TO POWER. INFREQUENTLY DID FROM
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
TO THE STATE BAR FROM DGS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO
CDC ARE FROM THE STATE LOTTERY
IN FISCAL TO SEE ISSUE. WHEN YOU
SEE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ITSELF. AND I GUESS I SHOULD ADD
IN THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES. ALAIN TOOK THEM ON
ALL OF THEM. PHRASES SUCH AS
INADEQUATE OVERSIGHT SIGNIFICANT
DELAYS BUDGET PRACTICES ARE
MISLEADING FAILURE TO DISCLOSE
TENS OF MILLIONS AND LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AND MANY OTHERS
PEPPERED THE REPORT SHE ISSUED.
CLEARLY ELAINE SPOKE AND THE
REST OF US LISTENED. IN DOING SO
SHE LIFTED ALL OF US UP AND MAKE
THIS WORK JUST A LITTLE BIT
HARDER. SHE WAS COMPLETELY
DEVOTED TO HER JOB TO US AND TO
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE.
I RECALL A PARTICULARLY
TURBULENT TIME FOR ELAINE THINK
IT WAS IN ABOUT TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. SHE WAS MOVING THROUGH
THE REAPPOINTMENT PROCESS AS OUR
STATE AUDITOR AND LYFT WAS NOT
BEING PARTICULARLY KIND TO HER.
ALESSER PERSON WOULD HAVE GIVEN
UP. FRANKLY I THINK I WOULD HAVE
. BUT NOT A LANE THERE WAS MUCH
WORK LEFT TO BE DONE THERE WERE
PEOPLE LEFT TO SERVE AND THERE
WERE THORNY ISSUES LEFT TO
ADDRESS. OBVIOUSLY IT ALL WORKED
OUT. SHE ACCEPTED THE
REAPPOINTMENT THE CHALLENGES
WERE RESOLVED UNFORTUNATELY FOR
ALL OF US ELAINE CONTINUED HER
EXTRAORDINARY PERFORMANCE AS OUR
STATE AUDITOR. BUT FOR METHAT
MOMENT IN TIME CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED THE TRUE MEASURE.
OF ELAINE HOW AND THE TRUE
MEANING OF THE PHRASE SERVICE
BEFORE SELF. YOU KNOW FOR MANY
OF US WE- SIMPLY PASSED THROUGH
LIFE JENNIFER LUCKY IN THE END.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO POINT TO ONE OR
TWO THINGS WE TOUCH WHERE
PERHAPS WE MADE AN IMPACT. BUT
DURING THAT JOURNEY IF WE ARE
REALLY VERY LUCKY. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE ALONGSIDE
SOMEONE WHOSE WORK ACTUALLY
CHANGE LIVES. WHOSE WORK
DIRECTLY IMPACTED OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CONSTITUENTS AND
WHOSE WORK ACTUALLY MADE. OUR
STATE A BETTER PLACE TO LIVE. IN
MY CASE I DID. AND THAT PERSON
WAS ELAINE HOW. SELAIN I CAN'T
SEE YOU UP THERE BUT THANK YOU
FOR SETTING THE BAR HIGH. THANK
YOU FOR TOLERATING ME AS YOUR
VICE CHAIR. AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING MY FRIEND. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR LEVEL. WELL I
THOUGHT I COULD TURN THAT AROUND
IN EIGHT YEARS I HAVEN'T LEARNED
THAT. STATE AUDITOR ELAINE HOWLE
ONE OF MY PERSONAL HEROES WHEN I
WAS ELECTED TO THE SENATE I'M
EMBARRASSED TO SAY I DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THERE WAS A THING AS A
STATE AUDITOR. AND THEN I WAS
PUT ON J. LACK AND I MET YOU.
AND YOU ARE SO FASTIDIOUS AND
IT'S ALWAYS THE FACTS MA'AM JUST
THE FACTS. NEVER DOUBTED
ANYTHING IN YOUR REPORTS BECAUSE
YOU OVERTURNED EVERY POSSIBLE
STONE. I GOT TO WHAT WE NEEDED
WHAT FOR THE FACTS. WHEN I HEARD
THAT YOU WERE RETIRING I'M OF
COURSE HAPPY FOR YOU. BUT YOU
ARE A GREAT LOSS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD SAY SOME
PEOPLE IN THIS BUSINESS STAY TO
LONG. THE GOOD ONES LEAVE TOO
SOON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
ENJOY YOUR RETIREMENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ. I WILL BE I'M
SORRY SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- ELAINE I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE I'VE HAD THE HONOR
OF SPENDING A FEW HOURS WITH YOU
REVIEWING SOME OF THE AUDITS
FROM MY COMMUNITY AND I JUST
WANNA SAY. YOUR PATIENCE YOUR
EDUCATION ARE GOING THROUGH THE
DETAILS FOR INTEGRITY EVERYTHING
THAT WE WANT ANNA AND A LEADER
SOUL WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU TO
YOU YOUR FAMILY TO YOUR SERVICE
TO CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE GOING TO
MISS YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR CALM WATER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I YOU KNOW I TO JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE FLOOR
AND SAY. HOW ELAINE HOW WILL
CERTAINLY BE MISSED BY MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY I'M GOING TO
SPEAK FOR THEM. THE SENATE. AND
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE. I
DID NOT SET ON DAY LACK WHEN I
HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
PRESENTING. MY AUDIT DESIRES TO
THEM. BECAUSE I LOVE A GOOD
AUDIT. AND WHAT ELAINE
REPRESENTS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHECK US AND NOBODY WANTS TO GET
CHECKED PEOPLE WANT TO DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO. BUT
THIS DEPARTMENT. HAS THE
CAPACITY AND THE DESIRE AND THE
PASSION AND THE COMMITMENT. TO
HELPING GOVERNMENT BE GOOD FOR
ALL OF US. AND THIS WOMAN HAS
LED A MAGNIFICENT TEAM. OF
CALIFORNIANS COMMITTED. TO
GIVING US THE INFORMATION THAT
WE NEED. TO CRAFT IN REDESIGN
GOOD POLICY. AND IT'S NOT SO
MUCH ABOUT CHECK IN SOMEBODY. AS
IT IS ABOUT MAKING SURE. THAT WE
ARE DOING ALL THAT WE CAN. TO
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITIES. TO
GIVE PEOPLE ACROSS THIS STATE
WHAT THEY NEED. RESOURCES ACCESS
HONESTY TRANSPARENCY AND A
COMMITMENT TO DOING BETTER SO I
JUST HAVE TO SHARE WITH YOU EVEN
THOUGH I CAN'T SEE YOU HOW
APPRECIATIVE I WAS OF YOU
HELPING ME WITH MY AUDIT BECAUSE
I CERTAINLY WAS TRYING TO CHECK
SOME DEPARTMENTS THAT I NO NEED
TO DO BETTER AND BE BETTER FOR
THE CONSTITUENTS THAT I
REPRESENT. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EAGLE EYES AND YOUR
COMMITMENT. TO THE TRUTH. AND TO
ARMING US WITH WHAT WE NEED MOST
REAL OBJECTIVE INFORMATION. I AM
WISHING YOU THE BEST IN YOUR
RETIREMENT AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU
ANY MORE COMMENTS FROM SENATORS
. DURING. NINE THANK YOU MEMBERS
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT TO THE. THANK YOU MISS
. I'LL BE OUT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE YOU.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY. ARTS CENTER LIMÓN I'M
SURE. THREE FILE ITEM A TEN FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE PLEASE
DEFINITELY THANK YOU. FOR CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
SENATORS STERN PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS IN THE ACTIVE
FILE FILE ITEM EIGHT TWENTY NINE
S. B. TWO NINETY ONE STERN. AND
FILE NUMBER A. THIRTY SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO STERN THANK YOU
EMISSIONS. THANK YOU TO JUST
WANNA. SENATOR SENATOR BATES YES
MR PRESIDENT UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM EIGHT TWENTY THREE SB SIX
FIFTY TWO FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE DOES
WANNA. SENATOR CAFIERO. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM SENATE
INACTIVE FILE AND RETURN THEM TO
THIRD READING EIGHT FOURTEEN SB
FOUR NINETY. A FIFTEEN SB FIVE
THIRTY TWO. A SIXTEEN SB THREE
EIGHTY TWO. A SEVENTEEN SB FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT AND A EIGHTEEN SB
SIX SEVENTY. THANK YOU THAT'S
ONE OF. I'M SORRY BURKE. IN
ORDER THEY WILL GO BACK TO
SECOND RAINY OKAY THANK YOU. NOW
BACK TO MOTIONS REAL RESOLUTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF JANUARY
FOR. THIRD THROUGH THE
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION ROLE SIXTY TWO
AA WILL BE WAIVED FOR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY JANUARY
TWENTIETH AT TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WITHOUT TWO DAYS NOTICE ON THE
DAILY FILE. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING THE BILL'S SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILLS EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY ONE AND SENATE
BILL EIGHT FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU
NOW MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE WE HAVE SECOND
READING FILE I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SEVENTY
AND SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY. NOW
MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS WE HAVE TO WE HAVE
CENTER BASE PREPARED FIRST ITEM
TWENTY FOUR. M. FOLLOWED BY THAT
TWENTY SIX CENTERBRIDGE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF CATHERINE'S A
LEFTY TO THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION APPEALS BOARD MISS
THE LEFTY HAVE SERVED ON THE
BOARD SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
HAVE SERVICE CHAIR SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PRIOR TO THIS ROLE SHE
WAS CHIEF COUNSEL AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS SHE WAS
APPROVED IN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY TWELFTH ON
A UNANIMOUS FIVE ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BUILT. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
NINETY NINE MANCHESTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER. FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO HI
PROTESTING AYE DALLY. DODD FIVE
EGGMAN. GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH FIVE HERTZBERG I PUESTO
HI FURTADO I JONES. I KAMLAGER.
I LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE THE MON I
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A CHIRLA. FIVE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH AYE RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER FIVE NUMBER. WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE WILK I.
I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL AFTER
MEMBERS. DALLY EGGMAN. MELENDEZ
ON BURKE. MY ANSWER TO PLEASE
CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS. SALLY
EGGMAN I. MELENDEZ ON BURKE.
FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
POINT IS CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON
OF. FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FOUL FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX IS A
CONFIRMATION OF THE FOLLOWING
APPOINTEES TO THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING DR JOSE
CARDENAS. MCKAY MICHAEL THERE
ARE TORY AND MEGAN GROSS THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JANUARY
TWELFTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTEES. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR THE BAY. HEARING
SEEN NINE MONTHS AFTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES I BAKER
FIVE FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD AYE
BY ADAM HI PROTESTING AYE DOLLY
. DODD FIVE EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH I HERTZBERG
BY WESTERN. HI FOR TORONTO HI
JONES I KAMLAGER. I LAYERED I
LEYVA I LIMON HI WIRE I MELENDEZ
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE TELEVOTE
AYE PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO. SKINNER HI I'M BURKE I
CASTING AYE WIENER I WILK I. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BALLY MELENDEZ RUBIO. I
UMBERG. FIVE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING
TO SENATE THIRD READING WE HAVE
EIGHT ITEMS FOR SENATE THIRD
READING ARE FIRST UP IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
ALLEN IS HE PREPARED. MOUNT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE OH TWO BY SENATOR ALAN
AN ACT RELATING TO HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS SENATOR ALAN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS UNDER CALIFORNIA'S GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM- OF THE
DEPARTMENT A TOXIC SUBSTANCE
ROLL INCENTIVIZE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS IN CONSUMER PRODUCTS
WITH THE GOAL OF FINDING
ALTERNATIVES IN DEVELOPING
REGULATIONS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH. UNFORTUNATELY AS
WE DO WE HAVE THE SCREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAMS NOW BEEN
AROUND FOR MORE THAN A DECADE.
AND NOT A SINGLE CHEMICAL IN A
CONSUMER PRODUCT HAS BEEN
SUBJECT TO REGULATORY RESPONSE
UNDER THIS FRAMEWORK. THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SLOW HI IS SO
SLOW IN IN LARGE PART DUE TO
DATA GAPS THAT HINDER INFORM
DECISION MAKING IN THE INABILITY
OF THE TSC. TO IDENTIFY
CHEMICALS IN PRODUCTS WITHOUT
DIRECTLY TESTING THEM OR DOING
VERY TIME CONSUMING SEARCHES OR
REQUESTS FOR DATA AND THERE'S A
WHOLE REPORT ON THIS STATE THAT
WE DRAFTED THIS BILL TO OUR
RESPONSE TO- SO SAID SO THIS
BILL SB FIVE OH TO IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM. PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTES ANALYSIS OF
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM
UNDER THE GST TO IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
STREAMLINE PROCESSES AND GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT AUTHORITY TO
COLLECT ESSENTIAL PRODUCT
INGREDIENT. DATA SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL GRANTS DGSE CLEAR
AUTHORITY TO OBTAIN PRODUCT
AGREED DATA FROM MANUFACTURERS
AND IF NEEDED. THE CHEMICAL
SUPPLIERS REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO ADOPT A SEVEN YEAR
TIMELINE TO IDENTIFY AND ASSESS
FIVE YEAR FIVE PRIORITY PRODUCTS
INDUSTRY MINDS INFORMAL
RESOLUTION APPEALS PROCESSES AND
CREATES A FAST TRACK. PROCESS
FOR WHEN EXISTING HIGH QUALITY
STUDIES SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT
MOVING QUICKLY TO REGULATORY
RESPONSIBLE TECH PUBLIC HEALTH.
WE FIRST INTRODUCED THE BILL
LAST SESSION WE WORKED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS ALL
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE OPPONENTS
ARE VERY PLEASED TO SAY. THAT
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS MEASURE
REFLECTS THE COMPROMISE REACHED
BETWEEN ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
BILL. HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTED
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
TROUBLED. THANK YOU MESSAGE
THREE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. I
SEE THAT THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
DTS SEEK TO IMPOSE FINES THAT
CAN BE UP TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DAY PER VIOLATION
FOR ALLEGEDLY FAILING TO PROVIDE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION TO THE D.
T. S. C. WHILE I AGREE. THAT
THEY SHOULD BE MAY ARE THAT WE
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA NOT BE EXPOSED TO
DANGEROUS CHEMICALS I FEEL THAT
A FIND COULD POTENTIALLY BE
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE.
BETTER FINE CAN POTENTIALLY BE
FIFTY FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DAY IS EXCESSIVE. SPECIALISES
THE BILL SEEMS TO NOT PROVIDE
ANY OPTION. FOR APPEAL. AB FOR
THE FINE TO EITHER THE COURTS OR
THE NEWLY CREATED BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY. WHICH IS
TASKED WITH OVERSEEING THE DGSE.
WITH ALL THAT IN MIND- HOW DID
YOU COME UP WITH SUCH A HIGH FEE
CAP IN WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO
REDUCING IT- AND DO YOU ENVISION
THERE BEING AN OPTION FOR PEOPLE
TO APPEAL THE FINE. FOR BOCH
CENTER HELLO YOU TAKE QUESTION
HAVE YOU TAKE THE QUESTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION. YOU KNOW LOOK WE ARE
THE THIS THERE'S A LONG
NEGOTIATION THE CAME INTO
PRODUCING THIS BILL- IN THE END
OF THE DAY ARE YOU KNOW IT IT IS
IT'S ARE STRONG WE GOT WE WERE
TRYING TO GIVE SOME TEETH TO THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM WE TOOK
HIM IN IN LOTS AND LOTS OF INPUT
FROM INDUSTRY IT'S WHY INDUSTRY
IS NOT- IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL HI SO WE ARE WE'RE IN A
PLACE WHERE WE REALLY WANT THERE
TO BE SOME TEETH- IF A IF A
PLAYER IS REPEATEDLY VIOLATING
IS NOT PARTICIPATING IS NOT.
BEING HELPFUL WE WANTED THERE TO
BE SOME TEETH IN THE BILL HI TO
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO DO ITS
JOB WHICH IS TO ENSURE THERE'S
NOT DANGEROUS TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
EVERYDAY PRODUCTS AS I SAY WE
HAVE THIS BECOMES THE PROGRAM
NOW FOR OVER A DECADE IN NOT A
SINGLE THERE HASN'T BEEN A
SINGLE MEANINGFUL REGULATORY
ACTION TAKEN OR EVEN INVENT OR
EVEN MEANINGFUL INVESTIGATION SO
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT IT'S
THERE FOR IT'S THERE TO GIVE
THEM SOME SOME TEETH. ARE
CERTAINLY HAPPY. TO TALK TO YOU
I MEAN I YOU KNOW I. GET WE
COULD TALK ABOUT A LOWER NUMBER-
BUT BUT WHAT I DON'T WANT TO
HAVE HAPPEN IS. IT THIS IS THEY
SAY. VIA WE RESOLVE THE CORE
CONCERNS OF THE FOLKS IN
INDUSTRY. AND I JUST I DON'T
WANT TO SEE US TAKE ACTION ON
THE FLOOR TODAY THAT- THAT THEY
THEY THEY MIGHT WEAKEN THE BILL
AND HERE'S THE THING. SENATOR
THE FOLKS WHO REPRESENT. ON THE
MORE LEGITIMATE. OUR PLAYERS IN
INDUSTRY I WERE FINE WITH THIS
PARTLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
TO HELP BAD ACTORS- YOU KNOW
THEY THEY THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THE DATE YOU'RE THE
FOLKS ARE PLAYING BY THE RULES.
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE MARKETS ARE A AND IN THE
FOLKS THAT ARE BREAKING THE
RULES ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
ADVANTAGES- AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
FINE OF FORTY FOR EVENTUALLY
DOES IT GIVES. THE DEPARTMENT
THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE THE RULES
WHICH AS I SAY INDUSTRY HAS
AGREED TO SELL I ULTIMATELY IS
ABOUT IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE ACROSS THE BOARD
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND AND IF THE
INDUSTRY PLAYERS THEMSELVES WHO
IN THIS CASE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT- THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT HELP TO
EMPOWER ABOUT ACTORS. IT SAYS
FAR. QUESTION TO- OF TROUBLE
CERTAINLY THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS. THE PRESIDENT- QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR IF I MAY GENERALLY
TAKE ANOTHER QUESTION YES HELLO.
THANK YOU SO IT'S ONLY BECAUSE
HE'S LEAVING AS SOON. SO THE DTS
SEE- IF IN INTO GIVEN ANYWHERE
FIND THE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A DAY- WE'RE WITH THAT PENALTY
GO WOULD GO TO THE T. S. C. OR
WHERE WOULD THE MONEY GO. YEAH
TYPICALLY- THERE'S A MECHANISM
FOR THIS AND I'M I'M- IT. THERE
THERE'S LIKE A FIND. YEAH RIGHT
IS A DGSE FIND IT WOULD GO TO. I
THEIR THEIR RULES THAT GOVERN.
ITS USE IN BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
SORT OF A TASK HE KNOWS MORE
ABOUT THE KIND OF THE ACTUAL
MECHANISM. OKAY I'LL WAIT FOR A
CENTER WHAT COUNTS YOU TO MAKE A
COMMENT- LAST QUESTION IS. IS IT
THROUGH THE CHAIR OR THE
PRESIDENT AGAIN- IS THERE A- OUT
OF POCKET- CAPACITY IN THIS
BILL. THAT WOULD ALLOW OUTSIDE
PLAYERS TO INITIATE- THIS-
FINANCIAL TRIGGER- IN A- IN A
POP UP FORMAT. NO I DON'T I
DON'T TO I DON'T THINK YOU'D SEE
A NO OPPOSITION THIS BILL IF
THERE WERE TWO SEVEN. YEAH NO NO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ONLY THE
DEPARTMENT COULD PURSUE. THANK
YOU SENATOR VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
PRESENT I DID HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHORED THAT BECAUSE OF
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM THE VALLEY
DIDN'T HAVE A MICROPHONE UP I
DIDN'T HEAR WHETHER IT'S THE
SAME QUESTION SO IF IT IS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER BUT I WAS
CONCERNED USUALLY THERE IS AN
APPEAL PROCESS AND I UNDERSTAND
THE- COULD NOBLE INTENTION OF
THIS BILL SOUTH FUNDING
QUESTIONS BUT I DO THINK A
PROCESS OF FULL VERY IMPORTANT.
IN TERMS OF TRUST IN AN AGENCY
WHEN HAVE SPECIFICALLY A
BUREAUCRACY AND THEY GET TO
LEVEL THE PINES AND THEY'LL FIND
THAT DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEBODY
OUT INTENTIONALLY VIOLATED LIKE
THE BAD ACTORS DO BUT NOT HAVING
AN APPEAL PROCESS WHEN YOU HAVE
A BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS THAT THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH IF TROUBLING.
SO IS THERE A REASON THERE IS
NOT AN APPEAL PROCESS AND IF YOU
ALREADY ANSWERED THAT I
APOLOGIZE. NO WE DIDN'T WE
ACTUALLY INTO IT I MEAN WHAT I
MEAN BECAUSE BROADLY SPEAKING IT
IS. AS I SAY WE WERE ABLE TO
SATISFY THE YOU KNOW THE COURT
CONCERNS OF OUR FRIENDS IN
INDUSTRY YOU. WORK IN THE SPACE.
BOB YOU KNOW THERE IS THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY YEAH THE DGSE HASTERT
THERE THERE'S A PRETTY STRICT
SET OF THE MINISTER OF OP
PROCEDURES THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
TO FOLLOW- BEFORE. I
IMPLEMENTING SOMETHING LIKE THIS
BUT- I SUPPOSE IN THE END OF THE
DAY IT'S JUST ABOUT IT'S YOU
KNOW IF THE IF IT'S ENSURING
THAT. THAT THIS PROGRAM ACTUALLY
HAS TEETH YOU KNOW. I THINK THAT
THE FEAR IS- AND I SAY THE FOLKS
REPRESENT INDUSTRY ARE ARE ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS BILL. OUT
BUT I THINK THE FEAR IS THAT
THERE WILL BE A FEW ACTORS OUT
THERE THAT WILL RUN THE PROCESS
OUT. AND AND IF IT EVER MEMBERS
JUST LET'S JUST REMEMBER THIS
FEET OF FORTIES ONLY FOR DATA
GATHERING. RIGHT SO IF YOU'RE
THIS IS JUST ABOUT ENSURING.
THAT THE THAT THAT THAT THE
PLAYERS WHO ARE BEING REGULATED
THIS PROGRAM ACTUALLY SHARING.
THEIR DATA HIS LISTED OUT IN THE
IN THE IN THE IN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE REPORT AND
IN THIS BILL. SO I HEAR YOU- BUT
YOU KNOW IT BUT- IT BUT THERE
THERE THERE THERE IS A- YEAH
WHAT BE THE BILL TALKS ABOUT HOW
THE- DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE TO-
YOU HAVE TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
ARE THE NATURE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE EXTENT OF THE
VIOLATION HISTORY OF PREVIOUS
VIOLATIONS. ON THE VIOLATOR'S
ABILITY TO PAY THE PENALTY- THE
DETERRENT EFFECT OF THE
PENALTIES ARE ALL THINGS OF THE
DEPARTMENTS TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. IN MAKING THIS
DECISION. I HAD. YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE IF THEY WERE
INTERACTING IN SOME KIND OF
ARBITRARY AND CAPRICIOUS MANNER
THERE'D BE A WAY. TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE THAT THIS WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WE YEAH THAT THAT
THAT THAT THAT. THAT THAT COULD
BE ADDRESS ANOTHER WAY BUT I
GUESS I WANTED BUT I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE HAPPEN. IS NOW GO
ANOTHER TWENTY YEARS WHERE EVERY
GROUP KNOWS THAT THEY CAN JUST.
APPEAL ARE WHEN IT WHEN THERE'S
BEEN A WISE DECISION MADE BY THE
BY THE DEPARTMENT AND ALL THE
SUDDEN WE'RE TWENTY YEARS LATER
WHENEVER TWO DECADES AND- AND
ONCE AGAIN THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
THING IS HAPPENING TO THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM. I THANK YOU
FOR THEIR DOUBTS ON MY OWN TIME-
COLLEAGUES I. BECOME MORE MORE
TROUBLED WITH THE AMOUNT. OF THE
THIRTY THAT'S DELEGATED FROM.
OUR LEGISLATIVE BODY AND I THINK
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT IN. A
PROPOSED REGULATIONS OF A
PROCESS THAT MUST BE FOLLOWED.
IN A DOZEN BECOME DISCRETIONARY
ON THE PART OF A VERY LARGE
BUREAUCRACY. WHO HAVE.
INCREDIBLE AUTHORITY TO FOR TO
FIND. AN INDIVIDUAL. COMPANY OR-
WHOEVER FIVE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY. SO WITHOUT AN
APPEAL PROCESS. OF FOR. SOMEONE
WHO'S MADE OF SOME SORT OF A
LAFAYETTE AND MINISTRY TO
MISTAKE. IT FOR A VERY TROUBLING
SO I THINK WHAT I'LL DO TODAY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE. THAT THE
INTENT HERE IS VERY. IMPORTANT
THAT WITHOUT SOME UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS C. AS IN IT. THE FAIR
ENOUGH THAT'S BUILT INTO THAT-
I'D GET ABSTAINED TODAY UNTIL I
CAN TAKE. A LITTLE CLOSER LOOK
AT THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR KABIR.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I HAD NO
INTENTION OF STANDING UP AND
SPEAKING TODAY BUT- I JUST WANT
TO TALK REAL BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
REASON THAT THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL WAS SET UP BECAUSE- I
WHILE I AGREE THAT IN MANY
INSTANCES I GET CONCERNED WITH
THE AMOUNT OF AUTHORITY THAT WE
GIVE TO OUR REGULATORY. ENTITIES
I'M PRETTY MUCH UNFETTERED TO
ADOPT REGULATIONS AND THEN TO
IMPOSE THEM I DO GET CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT AT TIMES THIS
SITUATION IS REALLY DIFFERENT
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL IS
LOOKING AT AND ANALYZING
CHEMICALS THAT WHEN PRODUCED
INTO A PRODUCT ARE DETRIMENTAL
TO THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING
EITHER OF CHILDREN OR PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND THE REASON
THAT THE GREEN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
WAS SET UP IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT FOR THE
CONCERNED ABOUT INADVERTENT
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES THAT'S
JUST NOT GONNA HAPPEN IN THIS
INSTANCE IT JUST ISN'T YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE PUTTING IN YOUR
PRODUCTS YOU KNOW WHETHER IT
HAS. CANCEROUS IMPACTS OR CAN
CAUSE OTHER DISRUPTION OF THE-
OF THE BODILY FUNCTIONS- THAT'S
WITH THE GREEN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
WAS SET UP FOR AND THE REASON IS
BECAUSE BACK IN THE DAY. THOSE
THAT THE CHEMICAL ****
COMPOSITIONS WOULD COME TO THE A
AND I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AT THE
TIME SO COME TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND WE WERE ASKED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER WE SHOULD BAN THE USE OF
THAT PARTICULAR CHEMICAL IN A
PARTICULAR PRODUCT AND I NEVER
SAT ON ANY OF THE COMMITTEES.
THAT DID THE REVIEW OF THESE
CHEMICALS AND YET THE BILL WOULD
COME TO THE FLOOR AND I'D HAVE
TO DECIDE WHETHER TO BAN THEM
PERMANENTLY FROM ANY PRODUCT
THAT WOULD COME INTO CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
TASK AND IT REQUIRED US TO KNOW
SOME PRETTY SOPHISTICATED
SCIENCE INFORMATION WHICH IS WHY
IT'S AT THE CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
WAIT WE DECIDED THAT WE NEEDED A
COUNCIL. OF EXPERTS THEY COULD
LOOK AT THIS INFORMATION AND
MAKE THE DECISION AND NOT HAVE
IT COME TO THE FLOOR EVERY
SINGLE- TIME THAT THERE WAS A
CONCERN ABOUT CHEMICALS SO I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL I AM
APPALLED THAT IN TEN YEARS
THERE'S BEEN NO ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTION TAKEN- EIGHT IT SAYS TO
ME THERE'S A PROBLEM- HOPEFULLY.
THIS WILL HELP TO RESOLVE SOME
OF THAT SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
BUT- BUT REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IF. IF A PRODUCT GETS
INTO PRODUCTION AND COMES TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING- ARE RESIDENTS SINCE
I WANT TO APPLY- MY GOOD
SENATOR- FOM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I THINK HE'S DONE A
GREAT JOB ON THIS HE WORKS
REALLY HARD ON THESE AND THE
FACT THAT THERE ISN'T. A GREAT
OPPOSITION FROM ON THE THOSE
THAT ARE REGULATED INDICATES
THAT THERE'S A SWEET SPOT HERE
AND I WANT TO ASK THAT YOU VOTE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE ON SENATOR
BACK. THANKS I JUST WANTED TO
TALK VERY BRIEFLY I TRY FIRST
ACTIVISM EVER WAS ON THE TOXIC
USE REDUCTION ACT IN
MASSACHUSETTS BUT WHEN I WAS IN
COLLEGE AND THEN THE C. WORKER
pTHE COMMUTER RIGHT TO KNOW ACT
SO I DID NOT KNOW ACTUALLY. AT
ALL REALLY ABOUT THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL THE WORK HAD
BEEN DONE BUT I THINK THE
EVIDENCE SPEAKS FOR ITSELF
TWELVE YEARS. WITHOUT A
ENFORCEMENT ACTION OR TO HAVE
THE EFFECT THAT SHOWS THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE THESE CHANGES AND I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHORED I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. ON THE SIDE OF. THE
FOR THE DISCUSSION OF RIGHTS
HERE IN CHINO IN. GENERAL TO
LOOK CLOSE APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION WEEK WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING HARD TO GET TO THE SWEET
SPOT THAT THEY MIGHT. MY FRIEND
FROM- FROM SALINAS I SUGGEST.
YOU KNOW TO REALLY THIS
DECISION- IS A IT'S A YES OR NO
QUESTION AS O WHETHER YOU
PROVIDE THE DATA. AS AS-
OUTLINED BY THE BILL- WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH INDUSTRY ON THIS-
THEY THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
THE BILL. THIS IS ULTIMATELY
ABOUT IMPROVING EFFICIENCY SO
THAT WE- CAN MAKE SURE THE
PRODUCTS ARE SAFER- IT'S ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THIS CREE
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM WHICH- WHICH
WAS LAUNCHED WITH SO MUCH
PROMISE. ACTUALLY HAS. SOME YOU
KNOW IS IT HAS AS SOME AS SOME
REAL. ENFORCEMENT POWER. AND SO
I WANT TO THINK THE ALL THE
SENATORS WHO SPOKE UP AND FOR
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION. AND I
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE THAT WILL. MAKE OUR
PRODUCTS SAFER. THANK YOU. THE
ANSWER TO PLEASE GO THE ROLL ON
FILE TWENTY NINE. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS AYE BATES
. BACKER FIVE FORTUS NO BRADFORD
FIVE CABALLERO I PROTECTING AYE
DOLLY. DODD FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG FIVE WESTERN HI
FURTADO I JONES NO KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED I LEYVA I LIMÓN FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO BUT CHAO OF BOTH. PAN
HI PORTANTINO. I BROUGHT I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER HI AMBER WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE WILK NOW
. I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES DALLYING.
MELENDEZ A TO A VOTE. I'M BURKE. HIS TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS FIVE
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
REMOVING ON A FILE ITEM THIRTY
ONE I CENTER SCANNER SHE
PREPARED FOR THE ITEM PASS ON
FILE ON FILE THANK YOU NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
ARE YOU PREPARED YES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO TRUST PASSING
DECLARING THE URGENCY BARRACKS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. OUR
INTERNAL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING SB
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT WHICH EXPANDS
THE TYPE OF EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS COVERED BY PENAL
CODE SIX TWENTY SIX TO INCLUDE
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
CURRENT LAW ONLY INCLUDES PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS THE INCLUSION OF PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WILL CREATE A CLEAR
STANDARD FOR THE ENFORCEMENT OF
TRESPASSING AT PRIVATE NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES SB SEVEN FORTY
RECOGNIZES THAT NONPROFIT HIGHER
EDUCATION HAS SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS IN
CONFRONTING SIMILAR PUBLIC
SAFETY HALLENGES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE
VERY ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING
INSANE ON. THEM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BECKER
AYE FORGES AYE BRADFORD HI BYRON
I PROTECTING AYE DALY. DOT I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
I FURTADO'S I JONES HI KAMLAGER
. LAYERED FIVE LEYVA FIVE LIMON
I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. NEWMAN
AYE NIELSEN. BUT CHAU BOTH AYE
PAN. I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO
I SKINNER I NUMBER AIKAU. I
WIENER AYE WILK I. I'M SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BALLY KAMLAGER. MELENDEZ NIELSEN
I- BURKE. THE SOONER MOVES
ACROSS. NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG HE'S PREPARED I AM.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO FIRE PROTECTION.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. I THINK
ALL OF US KNOW. ATTACKER I THINK
I THINK ARE DIFFERENT WE DON'T
RATE THAT WE'RE DOING THIRTY
THREE WOULD THAT'S THAT'S THIRTY
FOUR FIVE MAYOR BETSY FOUR FOUR
FOUR. FOR HIS FATHER AND THIRTY
THREE. RIGHT. OKAY I THINK I'M
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA YEAH HE
SUPPORTED ALL OF US KNOW MISTER
PRESIDENT THE IMPORTANT WORK
THAT I'M AMERICORPS DOES. IAN
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THESE ARE
CONSIDERED LOTUS CORRECTIVE TO
SECTOR HAS THREE DIRECT TARGET
PLEASE AS I THOUGHT YEAH. THE
BILL FOR FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION CHECK FOR TO MAKE IT A
TOP TWENTY. OUR CENTERS RECORD
YOUR PERFECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR PRESIDENT AS I WAS
SUGGESTING. NATIONAL SERVICE IS
IMPORTANT THERE'S A WHOLE GROUP
OF FOLKS THE AMERICORPS. THAT DO
AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. BUT THEY HAVE
SUPPORTED VACCINES SITES
CONDUCTING CONTACT TRACING UP
PROVIDED SURGE CAPACITY FOR CASE
INVESTIGATIONS DELIVERED FOOD TO
FAMILY AND NEEDS DELIVER CARE
DELIVER PACKAGES FOR SENIORS.
AND SO MUCH MORE. AND FOR THAT
THE TO VOTE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS OF SERVICE AND RECEIVE A
STIPEND OF TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
SOME OF THE MONEY. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND SOME
MONEY OF THE STATE GOVERNMENT
THE WAY THE LAW IS WRITTEN. IS
THAT. THEY PAY TAXES ON THE
STATE PORTION. THIS BILL MAKES A
CHANGE TO ALLOW THEM LIKE
STUDENTS WHO RECEIVE GRANTS TO
NOT HAVE TO PAY TAXES AS A
RESULT AS RIVAL. THANK YOU HE
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. NINETY
NINE MOUNT SECTOR. THIS YES THIS
IS ALL DOABLE FOR YOU NATURAL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A AND UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON. FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE.
HEARING C. NINE AUGUST THIRTY
FOUR KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR. SP FOUR
FIFTY MEMBERS ARE DIRECTLY
THROUGH. THE BILL FOR FIFTY BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO FIRE PROTECTION.
HERTZBERG THANK YOU. WE HAVE
HEARD ON THIS FLOOR AND- THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE PAPERS ACROSS
THE STATE. IN THE AIR WE BREATHE
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY WILDFIRE
SEASONS THE LARGEST IN HISTORY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS THE SECOND
WORST YEAR AND ALL THE
CONSEQUENCES. YOU SOLD OF THAT
THE VOTERS. PASSED PROPOSITION
NINETEEN WHICH DEDICATED PIECE
OF REVENUE FROM THAT PROP
NINETEEN ADDITIONAL REVENUE TO
CHANGE THE RULES TO FUND
WILDFIRE SUPPRESSION EFFORTS
ACROSS THE STATE. AS WE DEALT IN
THE DETAILS OF PROP NINETEEN IN
THIS AND OTHER MATTERS WITH THE%
FAMILY FARMS IN THE LIKE. WE
NEED TO MAKE SOME CORRECTIONS TO
IT IN THIS MEASURE BEFORE YOU
PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON HOW
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY TO
ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS. IN AREAS
MOST VULNERABLE TO THE STATE I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IS MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ERIN SHE
NINE. MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNITED IN UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR. NINETY
NINE OZ THIRTY FOUR KNOWS IT
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY MARIE. SENATE BILL SIX
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR EGGMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO WATER CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT
OF THE SENATE BILL SB SIX FIFTY
SIX IS A SYMBOL WATER BILL FOR
MY DISTRICT THAT JUST MEANT THE
YEAH THE END OF SESSION LAST
YEAR WITHOUT ENOUGH TIME I JUST
GIVE US ONE MORE TOOL TO DEAL
WITH OUR DR DROUGHT AND MANAGE
OUR SIGNAL REQUIREMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. NINETY NINE
MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE I'M THIRTY EIGHT. ALLEN
AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. I BAKER. I PORCHES.
BRADFORD AYE COMPARING AYE
PROTESTING AYE DALY DODD. I
EGGMAN I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG I WESTERN. I
FURTADO I JONES I KAMLAGER.
LAYERED I LEYVA HI LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I CONTROL OF BOTH. PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER I NUMBER WHITE
HOUSE HE I WIENER AYE WILK I.
I'M SICK- PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. PORGES DALLYING. GROVE
KAMLAGER. MELENDEZ A CHIRLA BOTH
. AMBERG PLEASE CALL THEM TO
MEMBERS. FORTUS DALLYING GROVE I
KAMLAGER. A CHORE MELENDEZ A
CHOI BOGUE I'M BURKE. CENTER
MOVE THE CALL. MEMBERS NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE SENATE ALONE SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY MARY. SENATE
BILL FIVE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
LIMÓN AND ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY CINEMA
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB FIVE FOR TWO WILL
CREATE A FIVE YEARS THE ONLY
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR ALL NEW
MEDIUM AND HEAVY. DUTY ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS IN ORDER TO ME
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AIR QUALITY
IN THE REMISSION VEHICLE GOALS.
EMISSIONS FROM THESE TRUCKS MAKE
UP A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION FOR
EXAMPLE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ABOUT 35% OF THE
TOTAL STATEWIDE KNOCKED
EMISSIONS. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THAT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FOUR TWO AND I COMMEND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA FOR
BRING IT FORWARD. AS YOU'RE
AWARE CALIFORNIA HAS ARTICULATED
AMBITIOUS GOALS TOWARD REPUBLIC
REDUCING OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. AND SETTING
AGGRESSIVE BUT ACHIEVABLE
STANDARD FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY TO EMULATE ON THE WAY
TOWARD CREATING THE KIND OF
CLEAN. AN INNOVATIVE ECONOMY
THAT THE CURRENT CLIMATE CRISIS
DEMANDS. A KEY ELEMENT OF A
LARGER PLAN IS A MANDATE TO THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
THROUGH GOVERNOR NUISANCE
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND SEVEN NINE
TWO ZERO. TO DEVELOP POLICIES TO
TRANSITION ALL MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES TO ZERO EMISSIONS.
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE THIS IS.
CHOSEN FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS GENERATE A SIGNIFICANT
SHARE OF HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION
ACROSS THE STATE. EACH YEAR. BY
WAIVING THE THREE POINT 9% A
STATE SALES TAX FOR THE PURCHASE
OF ZERO EMISSIONS TRUCKS SB FIVE
FOUR TWO WILL FACILITATE THE
TRANSITION. TO CALIFORNIA'S
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
FLEETS SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFORMING
THE SECTOR TRANSPORTATION BY
INCENTIVIZING THE PURCHASE. OF
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS OFFERS HUGE
POTENTIAL FOR MITIGATING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY ESPECIALLY
FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST IMPACTED.
COMMUNITIES IT'S IMPORTANT
CONSIDER THAT WHEN YOU PURCHASE
A ZERO EMISSIONS BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE A LARGE PART OF
THE UP FRONT COST. IS FOR THE
POWER IN THAT VEHICLE THAT COSTS
ESPECIALLY MORE THAN OFFSET. BY
THE REDUCED FUTURE COSTS ABOUT
MAINTENANCE AND FUEL. WHEN THE
REPLACEMENT IF YOU BUY BATTERIES
OR FUEL CELLS IS THE MECHANISM
FOR ELIMINATION OF GREENHOUSE
GAS CREATED BY CONVENTIONAL
VEHICLES. DEVISING MARKET BASED
APPROACHES TO ELIMINATING SUCH
UP FRONT COST BARRIERS. IS KEY
TO BUILDING THE DECARBONISATION
BY TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND
WILL ENABLE MORE CALIFORNIANS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS TRANSITION.
VERSION OF SB FIVE FOUR TO A
SENSIBLE AND PROMISING STEP IN
THIS REGARD WHICH IS WHY I'M-
PUTTING THE- AND I HEARD YOU ALL
TO DO THE SAME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE. ITEM SERVER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT CHRISTIAN
AUTHOR. THROUGH LIMÓN WE TOOK
QUESTIONS. M. I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I KNOW
EVERYBODY IS WORKING ON A
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND BUT THESE
ARE- HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS
THAT TRANSPORT GOODS AND
SERVICES AND I THINK THIS BILL
UNILATERALLY- TRIES TO CHANGE
THE WAY THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD
OPERATE IN TRANS PORTING TESE
GOODS- HAS THERE BEEN A STUDY
DONE ON THE SIDE EFFECTS I GUESS
YOU A COLUMN OR THE. THE THINGS
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH
IF THIS BILL PASSES AND THE
COSTS THAT WILL BE BORNE BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO TRANSPORT THESE
GOODS WHICH WILL ESSENTIALLY GO
ON TO THE CONSUMER HAS THERE
BEEN A STUDY DONE ON THE COST
AND THE SIDE EFFECTS OF. THE
NUMBER OF THAT QUESTION. YES IS
THERE A BEEN A STUDY DONE.
THAT'S MY QUESTION SIR THANK YOU
SO I AM NOT AWARE OF A STUDY
HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS A PORT IN MY
DISTRICT AND WE DO HAVE INDUSTRY
IMPORTS AND THOSE WHO TRANSPORT-
GOODS THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS THEY'RE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
PAY. A TO INVEST IN THIS
TECHNOLOGY I TO TRANSITION INTO
CLEANER VEHICLES THAT YOU TO DO
THIS NO MEDIUM TO HEAVY DUTY-
TRANSPORTATION OF GOODS TO BE
ABLE TO I DO GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO CONTINUE.
DOING THE WORK THEY DO IN TERMS
OF THE TRANSITION AND IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SO I DO HAVE
INDUSTRY AND US SUPPORT FROM OUR
PARTS. THANK YOU ON MY OWN TIME
I UNDERSTAND EVERYBODY'S TRYING
TO GO BUT I JUST THINK THAT.
EVERYBODY'S ON THE GREEN
BANDWAGON IN THERE NOT THINKING
THROUGH THE FULL PROCESS I THINK
THAT. CONVERTING THESE VEHICLES
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ONLY
WILL AND HAS CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS TO. CARRY THE BURDEN
OF A HUGE COST. WITH ALREADY
INFLATION RISING TREMENDOUSLY
THESE COSTS WILL BE PASSED ON TO
THE CONSUMER. THE PEOPLE. IN YOU
KNOW EIGHT DOLLARS FOR BACON
VERSUS THREE DOLLARS FOR BACON.
OR SIX DOLLARS FOR A DOZEN EGGS
VERSUS TWO DOLLARS FOR A DOZEN
EGGS BECAUSE TRANSPORTATION. IS
A COST FACTOR ON THE THINGS THAT
ARE CONSTITUENTS PURCHASE EVERY
DAY. I CAN ALSO TELL YOU. THAT
WHAT DO YOU DO I MEAN THERE'S NO
STUDY DONE ON INTERSTATE TRAVEL
SO IF YOU. LIKE FOR INSTANCE I
PRODUCE- 99% I PRODUCE MY
CONSTITUENT PRODUCES 99% OF THE
BABY CARROTS THAT ARE. GROWN IN
THE UNITED STATES 99% ALMONDS
90% OF THE- WALNUTS AND A LARGE.
A PORTION OF THE CITRUS
COMMUNITY WHETHER IT'S CUTIES
ARE HALOS. STONE FOR EXCEPT IN
THE NORTHERN PART PART OF THE
SET THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND
IF YOU HAVE TO DRIVE THIS TYPE
OF TRUCKING CALIFORNIA BUT YOU
TRANSPORT THESE PRODUCTS ALL
OVER THE NATION. EITHER BY RAIL
OR BY TWO AND TRANSPORTATION. DO
YOU HAVE TO DRIVE A REGULAR
DIESEL TRACKING. NUMBER NOT IN
CALIFORNIA I MEAN I JUST DON'T
THINK THE WHOLE THING IS THOUGHT
THROUGH AND I THINK THERE'S
GOING TO BE A HUGE BURDEN. ON
OUR CONSTITUENTS- COST OF THESE
THESE PRODUCTS TO BE TRANSPORTED
FROM. WHETHER IT'S THE PORTS TO
THE SUPERMARKETS OR IT'S THE YOU
KNOW FARM TO FORK THAT WE ALWAYS
SAY. THIS TRANSPORTATION COSTS
IS GOING TO HURT OUR
CONSTITUENTS AT. ASPIRIN WILL
THE INTO BE. GET A STEADY. TO
FIND OUT HOW MUCH THIS IS GOING
TO AFFECT THE COST OF REGULAR
DATE FOOD ITEMS. THAT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA- ARE PURCHASING
EVERY DAY THANK. THANK THANK YOU
CENTER NELSON ALL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. NINETY NINE SENATE ALONE
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THIS IS A TAX BREAK- AND SO THIS
IS FOR NOT REQUIRING ONE VEHICLE
OVER ANOTHER TO DO THE
TRANSPORTATION AND THIS IS A TAX
BREAK THAT IS WELCOME BY THOSE
THAT ARE IN THE INDUSTRY DOING
THE TRANSPORTATION OF HEAVY
LOADS. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I. J.
WITH HER ARM MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BATES. AYE BAKER FIVE FORGES I
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
PROTECTING AYE DOLLY. DODD I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG BY WESTERN. I
HER TADO. HI JONES HI KAMLAGER
HI LAYERED I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A TROUBLE I CAN I
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER I NUMBER I CASTING
FIVE WIENER I WILK HI I'M
SURGERY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLY GROVE. MELENDEZ
AMBERG AUGUST THIRTY THREE KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON THE NEXT TIME
WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL MEMBERS TO
REMAIN ON THE FLOOR IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE PLEASE REMAIN ON THE
FLOOR NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FORTY BY SENATOR LIMON
HE'S PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
MARY SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR LIMÓN AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE AGENCIES
CINEMA. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
NONPROFIT SECTOR IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN OUR STATE
WHICH GENERATES ONE SXTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S GROSS STATE PRODUCT
AND PRODUCES OVER FORTY BILLION
INTO THE STATE EACH YEAR FROM
OUT OF STATE RESOURCES DESPITE
THE VITAL ROLE THAT NONPROFITS
PLAYING CALIFORNIA SERVICES
SUPPLY CHAIN AND ECONOMY THEY
HAVE NO DESIGNATED GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL TO HELP THEM ADDRESS
CHALLENGES AND OUR PARTNERSHIPS
WITH STATE AGENCIES NAVIGATE
AGENCY REGULATIONS OR IMPROVE
AGENCY CONTRACT PRACTICES TO
INCREASE PROGRAM EFFECTIVENESS
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
STATE AGENCIES THAT REGULATE OR
IMPACTS SMALL BUSINESSES TO HAVE
A SMALL BUSINESS LIAISON BUT
THERE IS NO EQUIVALENT FOR NON
PROFITS. SB FIVE FOUR THREE
REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY REGULATE OR IMPACT
NONPROFITS TO DESIGNATE AT LEAST
ONE PERSON AMONG AMONGST
EXISTING PERSONNEL TO PERFORM
THE DUTIES OF NONPROFIT LIAISON
AND TO ADVERTISE THE EXISTENCE
OF THE LEASE ON WHAT IT IS
HOMELESSNESS NATURAL DISASTERS
OR CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR HAS TOUCHED
THE LIVES OF CASH EVERY
CALIFORNIANS SB FIVE OR THREE
WILL ENSURE THAT THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR HAS THE NECESSARY STATE
SUPPORT PROVIDES CRITICAL
SERVICES TO OUR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IBM.
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION
DEBATE SENATOR BORDERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I THINK IF YOU
GO BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY AND
PUT YOURSELF IN THE POSITION OF
FOLKS THAT WANT TO DO BUSINESS
WITH THE STATE OR WITH. THEIR
COUNTIES OR COMMUNITIES. BERMAN
YOU'RE ALL SEEKING TERRIBLE
INTIMATE. AND SO THE SAME WE
BUSY. BETTER COPE IS- TO HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES INTERFACE WITH
GOVERNMENT- INSTRUMENTS WE SHARE
THE SAME THING WHEN IT COMES TO
NONPROFITS WHETHER YOU'RE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. OR SOME
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION HAVE THE INTERFACE
MAKES GOVERNMENT ACCESSIBLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION INNOVATIVE HEARING
THREE NINE MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING.
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF FALLEN
FORTY- NINETEEN NINE OZ THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVES MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO OUR LAB SO I DON'T FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR BUT SENATOR WIENER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO VENDING MACHINES SURE WINNER
I THANK YOU. MR PRESIDENT OUR
COLLEAGUES SB TWO TWO FIVE IS A-
A CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL- THAT
WILL REQUIRE ON VENDING MACHINES
IN ADDITION TO. LISTING THE NAME
AND ADDRESS OF THE OWNER OF THE
VENDING MACHINES SO THE CONSUMER
CAN COMMUNICATE WITH THE HONOR
ALSO TO LIST EITHER A PHONE
NUMBER. OR AN EMAIL ADDRESS. A
RESPECTFULLY THAT'S WHEN I GO.
EIGHT ANY FOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. THREE MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR. ALLEN. FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS AYE BATES
. BAKER ARE YOU PORGES. BRADFORD
I HAVE A ADAM I PROTESTING AYE
DALY. DODD I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE I HERTZBERG
AYE WESTERN. I HER TADO. HER
TADO. I JONES. KAMLAGER I
LAYERED FIVE LEYVA I LIMON AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. A CHOI BOGUE I PAN. I
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE WHITE HOUSE
SKI. I WIENER I WILK. MMHM
SURGERY PLEASE CALL UP TO
MEMBERS. BATES FOR JUST. DALLY
JONES. MELENDEZ NIELSEN AMBERG
WILK THE IRISH TWENTY NINE KNOWS
IT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
NUMBERS RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS NOW IS THE TIME FOR
. ARE WE GOT A. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA LOOK TO BECAUSE WE HAVE A-
TWO ITEMS ON CALL WE HAVE FILE
ITEMS THIRTY TWO AND THIRTY
EIGHT WE'RE GONNA LOOK CALL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. DALLY
KAMLAGER. FIVE MELENDEZ AMBERG.
ARE YOU THIRTY FOUR ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY FOUR ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. PORGES DALLY KAMLAGER I.
MELENDEZ A CHOI BOGUE AMBERG.
ARE THESE THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS
WERE RETURNING BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RENTAL RESOLUTIONS NOW IS
THE TIME FOR A JOURNEY MEMORIES
. WE HAVE SENATOR PROBLEM LONGER
YOU PREPARED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THIS AFTERNOON I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
THREE SOME ACCORDING. TO SOME OF
COURT WAS BORN NOVEMBER TWENTY
FOURTH NINETEEN FIFTY SIX IN
SAINT LOUIS MISSOURI AND
RELOCATED. TO CALIFORNIA WITH
HER FAMILY AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN. SHE STARTED WORKING
AT SAVE ON DRUGS IN THE LATE
SEVENTIES AS A PHARMACEUTICAL
TECHNICIAN. WHICH PREPARED HER
FOR TWENTY FOUR YEAR LONG CAREER
AT CORAL CHEMICAL IN PARAMOUNT
CALIFORNIA. AFTER RETIREMENT
STILL FULL OF LIFE SHE STARTED
SHE SAYS GOURMET CATERING. AND
WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY
PROVIDING EVENT MEALS IN
PLANNING. THIS WAS A NATURAL
CALLING YEAH SHE WAS PRAISEDFAR
AND WIDE FOR MAKING THE BEST OF
EVERYTHING AND WOULD OFTEN
CREATE DISHES JUST TO SEE WHAT
THEY WERE LIKE. AND IF THEY WERE
LIKE AND BOY WERE THEY- THIS
JOURNEY THE ROAD THOUGH VERY
REWARDING WAS JUST THE OPEN DOOR
TO HER TRUE PASSION OF SERVICE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTY CENTS
BEGAN WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE DAVIS FOR THE FORTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. AFTER
LEAVING THE ASSEMBLY OFFICE
THREE SECOND TENURE HER ROLE OF
SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY LEADERS
AND POLITICAL PURPOSE THROUGH
VARIOUS AVENUES INCLUDING SENIOR
SERVICE FUNDRAISING AND CAMPAIGN
OPERATIONS FOR THOSE THAT WOULD
WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. HER
RECENT PAP WAS ONCE AGAIN IN
SERVICE OF THE COMMUNITY AND
HELPING OTHERS AS THE OPERATIONS
MANAGER FOR C. R. C. D.
ENTERPRISES. SHE LOVED THIS ROLE
AS SHE WAS ABLE TO ASSIST YOUNG
AND OLD WITH EMPLOYMENT.
REEMPLOYMENT AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH. AND HAD AN AUDIENCE
FOR HER GIVING PERSONALITY AND
PASSION TO SEE OTHERS SUCCEED.
SHE NEVER GAVE UP HER PASSION
FOR COOKING AND WOULD OFTEN COOK
HUGE MEALS BEATING THE WHOLE
STAFF JUST BECAUSE SHE LOVED TO
SEE THEM SMILE. AND ENJOY HER
GIFT. THERESA WAS HUMOROUS
ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN A
PROFESSIONAL COMEDIAN SHE WAS SO
SPONTANEOUS AND HAD A COMEDIC
DELIVERY THAT WAS SPOT ON AND
TREES ARE ALWAYS LEFT US. WITH
LAUGHTER AND A SMILE. SHE LEAVES
TO SURVIVE HER. HER MOTHER
LIZZIE MCCOY'S DAUGHTER AUTUMN
SUN RAHEEM. GRANDDAUGHTER
DORIAN'S SISTER MARGARET BROTHER
IN LAW CARLTON. UNCLES NIECES
AND NEPHEWS AND A HOST OF
RELATIVES AND FRIENDS THREE SO
WILL BE MISSED. BY ALL THOSE SHE
TOUCHED WITH HER LIFE OF IVING.
MATRI SOME ACCORD REST IN POWER.
AND MAY HER MEMORY BE A
BLESSING. I ASK THAT YOU ADD HER
NAME TO THE FILE THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER WHICH TO BRING THE
NAME FOR TOOK ME PROBABLY GERMAN
BROTHERS CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. NOT SERVICE CENTER
NIELSEN. SPASM LDIES AND
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE. I REQUEST
THAT WE HAD GERMAN HONOR TODAY
OF ONE OF THE QUIET LEGENDS OF
THIS CAPITAL. FRANK HOPKINS. WAS
A LONG TIME COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR FOR THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE SENATE. HE HAD A
LONG CAREER. HE SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES AIR FORCE. AND HE
WAS A RADIO PERSONALITY. ON THE
SAME RADIO STATION THAT THE
FAMOUS GOOD MORNING VIETNAM.
CHAU ERDOGAN. HE THEN CAME TO
SACRAMENTO. AND BEGIN WORK HERE
IN THE STATE CAPITAL. HE WAS A
GREAT PHOTOGRAPHER. AND WE'RE
GREAT AT GETTING OUR MESSAGE OUT
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS. I
REMEMBER THE- TINY OFFICE THAT
FRANK HAD I BELIEVE WAS ON THE
THIRD FLOOR YOU COULD BARELY
TURN AROUND IN IT BUT THAT DID
NOT DETER FRANK FROM DOING HIS
GREAT JOB. AND HE WOULD ALWAYS
BE ON TOP OF THE ISSUES WELL
PREPARED. AND WOULD BRIEF THE
MEMBERS THOROUGHLY. AS TO
WHATEVER WE WERE GOING TO BE
DOING. HE HAS SERVED FOR DECADES
HERE IN THIS INSTITUTION A QUIET
DRIVING FORCE TOTALLY CREDIBLE
WITH THE MEDIA. WHEN FRANK
CALLED THEY ANSWERED. I WENT
BACK CALLED WE RESPOND. THIS IS
ONE THAT KIND OF MAKES ME SIGH
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THIS GOOD MAN
. HERE'S ANOTHER OF THOSE FEW
WHO ARE STILL VERY QUIET ABOUT
THIS PLACE. DON'T GAIN A GREAT
DEAL OF NOTORIETY. AND SELDOM
NEAR ENOUGH BIG KNOWLEDGE FOR
WHAT HE DID. HE RETIRED THE
DAVIS. HE WANTED TO BE NEAR HIS
DAUGHTER. CHRISTINE. HE LOST HIS
WIFE A FEW YEARS PRIOR TO THAT
CINDY. CRISTINA STILL AROUND
STILL STAYS IN TOUCH. IN HER
FATHER'S MEMORY. HE WAS
RESPECTED ON ALL MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THOUGH HE DIDN'T DO
ACTUALITIES PICTURES FOR THE
DEMOCRATS THEY HAVE THEIR OWN.
ALL RESPECTED FRANK HOPKINS. AND
HE HAS PASSED AWAY DUE TO ELSE
TIMERS. WE'RE TRULY A QUIET
LEGEND THE MAN OF ACCOMPLISHMENT
A CREDIT TO THE SENATE. I
REQUEST THAT WE IN GERMANY HONOR
FRANKOPAN SHOULD ONE OF OUR OWN
. THANK YOU PLEASE BRING THE
NAME FOR TO IT CAN BE PROBABLY
MORE LIES. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF TRISTEN
CROW GIVES A MARINE CORPS
VETERAN A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS
LEADER A DEDICATED COMMUNITY
VOLUNTEER A DEAR PERSONAL FRIEND
AND FATHER OF ONE OF OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE STATE SENATOR AND
CONGRESSWOMAN MIMI WALTERS.
TROSZYN PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY
ON DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
EIGHT HE WAS BORN IN CTENOPHORES
EVELYN AND EMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES WITH HIS MOTHER A
UNITED STATES CITIZEN AND HIS
BROTHER IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
AS A REFUGEE FROM THE RUSSIAN
INVASION OF FINLAND. HIS FATHER
REMAIN BEHIND UNTIL THE END OF
WORLD WAR TWO IN AND JOIN THE
FAMILY AND THEY ALL SETTLED IN
BROOKLYN HEIGHTS FOLLOWING HIGH
SCHOOL TRIPS ONE IN AN ROTC
SCHOLARSHIP AND ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF NEW MEXICO. WHERE
HE MET HIS WIFE TO BE BARBARA
RAFI DUE TO PARENT OPPOSITION TO
THE RELATIONSHIP TRIPS AND
BARBARA A LOOK TONIGHT TÍNH
FIFTY TWO BUT FINALLY ONE
PARENTAL APPROVAL AND SET UP
HOUSEKEEPING IN NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO AND BEGAN BEGAN THEIR
MARITAL LOVE AFFAIR LASTING
SIXTY NINE YEARS. TRANSGRESSION
WAITED FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
NEW MEXICO IN NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR AND JOINED THE US MARINE
CORPS AS A COMMISSIONED OFFICER
BEGINNING HIS HEARING SERVE.
BASIS ABROAD AND THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES AND- CAMP
PENDLETON. THE ACTIVE DUTY. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY. TO BEGIN A
CAREER IN BUSINESS WHICH HE
PURSUED IN MANY COMPANIES THE
SENDING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE.
TO PRESIDENT OF HUNT WESSON
FROZEN AND RICHARD REFRIGERATED
FOODS DIVISION OF FULLERTON
CALIFORNIA. WHICH COMPLETED
TRIPS AND BARBERS DREAM TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA THEIR PERMANENT HOME.
BY THE ENTRANCE AND BARBARA HAD
SIX CHILDREN INCLUDING MANY WHO
IS SECOND FROM THE YOUNGEST. AND
BUILT THEIR DREAM HOME IN THE
MODERN BE TERRORISTS THE COASTAL
COMMUNITY AN UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITY OF LAGUNA GAL. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX MODERATE B.
TERRACE WAS REMOVED FROM THE
LIST AGAIN AND AGO PROPOSED CITY
BOUNDARY IN PLACE WITHIN THE
PROPOSED CITY BOUNDARY. OF DANA
POINT AFTER A VERY LONG
CORPORATION BATTLE OVER THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE TWO CITIES.
AND THAT IS WHEN I FIRST MET
TRIPS AS HE STOOD WITH ME. IN
OUR TWO YEAR UNSUCCESSFUL
EFFORTS TO KEEP MODERATE BE
TERRORISTS. IN THE COASTAL AREA
WITHIN THE PROPOSAL. A GOOD IN A
GAL CITY BOUNDARY. MY NEXT SIDE
BY PARTNERSHIP WITH CHRIS IN THE
MID NINETIES WHEN ORANGE
COUNTY'S EL TORO MARINE BASE IS
SLATED FOR CLOSURE IN THE COUNTY
WAS PLANNING TO BUILD. A
COMMERCIAL INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
ON THE CLOSE BASS. TRISTAN TEND
TO THE BATTLE AGAIN NOW WITH A
MASTER'S DEGREE AND A LAW DEGREE
AND BECAME A FORCEFUL LEADER
THIS TIME IN OUR SUCCESSFUL
EFFORT TO DEFEAT THE
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT PLAN.
TRIPS WAS IN MY ESTIMATION TRULY
A RENAISSANCE MAN. NOT ONLY
COMMITTED TO THE CAUSE AS I HAVE
MENTIONED THAT RECOGNIZED FOR
HIS ABILITY HIS COMMITMENT AND
HIS EFFORTS WERE MANY OTHER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. HE
SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE SOUTH
COAST MEDICAL CENTER BOARD WHICH
BECAME PROVIDENCE MISSION
POSSIBLE. AND HE PROVIDED PRO
BONO LEGAL SERVICES TO THE
PUBLIC LAWCENTER OF SANTA ANA.
HE VALUED THE GOLDEN APPLE
AWARDS FROM THE STUDENT BAR FOR
HIS TEACHING AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
ABOVE ALL CHRIS WAS A DEVOTED
HUSBAND AND LOVING FATHER.
ALWAYS ENCOURAGING AND
SUPPORTING HIS CHILDREN IN ALL
ENDEAVORS AND WALKING THEIR UPS
AND DOWNS WITH THEM. I ASKED ME
IF SHE WOULD SHARE WITH ME A
FATHER DAUGHTER MOMENT THAT I
MIGHT SHARE WITH OUR SENATE
COLLEAGUES. A MAD PERMISSION TO
READ. PERMISSION RACK MIMI SAYS
THE FIRST TIME I RAN FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE WAS FOR LAGUNA HILLS CITY
COUNCIL IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
SINCE I HAD GROWN UP IN LAGUNA
MIGUEL DAD THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO CAMPAIGN
USING MY MAIDEN NAME MY CAMPAIGN
SIGNS RED MINI CHROMEOS WALTERS
THAT THINKING THAT WOULD HELP ME
WIN UNFORTUNATELY IT DIDN'T I
LOST THE ELECTION PROTEAS IS NOT
EXACTLY AN EASY NAME TO REMEMBER
AND THAT WAS THE LAST TIME WE
AGREED WE WOULD NOT USE IT IN
ANY CAMPAIGN MATERIAL. TRIPS
WILL BE SORELY MISSED BY HIS
EXTENDED FAMILY AND BY THE
COMMUNITY THAT HE WORKED
ALONGSIDE AND CARED SO VERY MUCH
ABOUT. IN CLOSING I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
TRISTEN CROKE YES AND SEND OUR
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY. THANK
YOU SOONER VETERANS TO BRING THE
NAME FOR TO A CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHER. NEXT UP IS SENATOR ALAN
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE TO
DURING THE MEMORY OF SIDNEY
POTIER- CONSTITUENT OF MY TWENTY
SIX DISTRICT. THIS PASSED AWAY
ON JANUARY SIX THE RIPE AGE OF
NINETY FOUR. THE BELOVED AROUND
THE WORLD. MISTER TWENTY WAS AN
AWARD WINNING ACTOR FILM
DIRECTOR DIPLOMAT AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVIST. HE WAS BORN IN
MIAMI IN NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN
BUT THEN SPENT MUCH OF HIS
CHILDHOOD IN THE BAHAMAS GREW UP
VERY IMPOVERISHED- AND THEN- AND
THEN CAME. BACK TO FLORIDA. WHEN
HE WAS FIFTEEN AND THEN MAYES
WHERE TO NEW YORK- BEFORE
EVENTUALLY FINDING HIS WAY WEST
HERE. TO CALIFORNIA. BUT IT'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY STORY OF SOMEONE
WHO HAD NO ACTING TRAINING AS A
YOUNG PERSON. I FACT I HEARD AN
INTERVIEW NOT TOO LONG AGO
ABOUT. HOW HE SHOWED UP AT THE
AMERICAN NEGRO THEATER IN NEW
YORK CITY- YEAH I SAID IT HE
SAID I WANT TO ACT. AND THEY
THEY HAD HIM DO A LITTLE READ
THROUGH AND HE LITERALLY. COULD
BARELY READ. AND THEY KICKED HIM
OUT HE SAID GET OUT OF HERE. GO
GO WATCH THIS IS. AND HE ENDED
UP. BEFRIENDING AN OLDER
GENTLEMAN WHO REALLY HELPED THEM
RE GET GET HIS READING SKILLS UP
. ANY MAYES WAY BACK TO THE
THEATER TRIED OUT EVENTUALLY
SAID HEY LOOK WE REJECTED HIM
AGAIN HE SAID LOOK LET ME BE A
JANITOR HERE AND MAYBE YOU CAN
HELP ME. GET BETTER. AND HE BE
PUT IN THE WORK AND ULTIMATELY.
YOU HAVE PERFECTED HIS READING
SKILLS AND ULTIMATELY BECAME ONE
OF THE MOST LEGENDARY ACTORS. OF
OUR DAY. AND OF COURSE. HE WAS A
LEGENDARY ACTOR IN HIS OWN RIGHT
BUT BUT YOU KNOW. WE CAN'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE V. CREDIBLE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS MAN. WITH
REGARDS TO THE TRAILBLAZING THAT
HE DID- AS A- AS A AS A BLACK
MAN IN IN HOLLYWOOD. I BECAME
THE FIRST BLACK ACTOR NOMINATED
FOR BEST ACTOR ACADEMY AWARD IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT THE VERY
FIRST. FOR HIS GROUND BREAKING
PERFORMANCE IN THE DEFIANT ONES
A WONDERFUL MOVIE FURTHER
CEMENTING HIS PLACE IN HOLLYWOOD
HISTORY WHEN IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR HE BECAME THE VERY FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN. TO WIN AN
ACADEMY AWARD IN A LEADING ROLE
CATEGORY FOR BEST ACTOR IN HIS
ROLE IN LILIES OF THE FIELD. AND
COURSE WAS DECADES UNTIL ANOTHER
BLACK PERSON ONE WON THE OSCAR.
NOT ONLY WAS CITY IT.
EXTRAORDINARY TALENT STAGE AND
SCREEN HE WAS A LIFELONG
STEADFAST CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVIST.
HE PARTICIPATED IN START
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON HE JOINED HIS CLOSE
FRIEND HARRY BELAFONTE. IN
FREEDOM SUMMER IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR. ON A HARROWING TRIP TO
MISSISSIPPI AT THE HEIGHT. OF
THE STRUGGLES FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
WHEN HE IN AND MISTER BELL FINDS
A WERE PICKED UP AT THE LOCAL
AIRPORT BY MEMBERS OF SNACK. THE
SAID THIS DID NOT BY ACCORDING
COMMITTEE THEY WERE AGGRESSIVELY
CHASING ULTIMATELY SHOT AT. BY
MEMBERS OF THE KU KLUX KLAN. HIS
ACTIVISM INFUSED IS ACTING
WORKED AS WELL PARTICULAR
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN WHEN HE
STARTED THREE GROUNDBREAKING
ROLE CENTERED ON RACE.
REDEFINING PARTS WRITTEN FOR
BLACK ACTORS REJECTING THOSE
BASED ON WHAT RACIAL
STEREOTYPES. ARE THERE'S ANY
THERE'S A MOMENT IN- AND YOU
KNOW IF THEY'VE IS BEEN REPLETE
PLAY MANY MANY TIMES- IN A IN A
SCENE WHERE HE WAS. GOING TO GO
DOWN SOUTH TO. INVESTIGATE A
MURDER AND- HE WAS SAYS SLAPS ON
SCREEN THAT'S PART OF THE SCRIPT
CALLED FOR HIM TO BE SMACKED BY
A POWERFUL WHITE PERSON. WHO HE
WAS GOING TO INVESTIGATE AND THE
SCRIPT ORIGINALLY CALLED FOR HIM
TO NOT REACT TO JUST TAKE THE
BLOW. AND HE INSISTED HE SAID
I'M NOT I'M ONLY GOOD ACTORS
PART IF I CAN SMACK IN RIGHT
BACK AS AN IMMEDIATE REACTION
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH. A NATURAL
REACTION AND I WOULD BE. I WOULD
BE BETRAYING. EVERYBODY PERSON
IN AMERICA WHAT IN RESPOND THAT
WAY. AND SURE ENOUGH. I BBV
PLAYED TO SEE HOW HE WON THE
SCENE PLAYED INTO BECOMING ONE
OF MOST POWERFUL SCENES IN MOVIE
MAKING. AND THERE'S THIS
WONDERFUL SONORA PANS TO THE
LOCAL SOUTHERN SHERIFF AND- EMMA
IN THE COURSE THE GUY WHO JUST
GOT SMACKED BACK SAID YOU WHAT
DO YOU DO BY THE LOOKS HE SAYS.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW. AND THERE A
IT WAS A REALLY POWERFUL MOMENT-
THEY THEY THEY KIND OF THAT
SHOOK UP. OUR BASIC CONCEPTS OF
RACIAL STEREOTYPES THAT IS SO
DOMINATED HOLLYWOOD UP TO THAT
MOMENT AND CONTINUE TO FOR QUITE
SOMETIME AFTER- BUT IT'S JUST
ONE ONE SMALL EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
TRAILBLAZER HE WAS. HE WAS A
TREASURED RESIDENT MY DISTRICT
FOR NUMEROUS YEARS THAT YOU'VE
MANY CONSTITUENTS WITNESSES
KINDNESS AND GENEROSITY. HIS
SUPPORT FOR THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY A LOVING
LOVING FAMILY HIS WIFE JOANNA
FIVE AND SIX DAUGHTERS EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN THREE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. AND I JUST HOPE
THAT HIS MEMORY WILL CONTINUE TO
BE AN INCREDIBLE BLESSING AND IT
MAYES LEGACY CONTINUES. TO
INSPIRE US AND ASKED WE ANSWERED
IN THE EXTRAORDINARY OF SIDNEY
POTIER. THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
CENTER BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I TO WANT TO RISE
AND LEND MY VOICE TO. THE GERMAN
OF SYDNEY PORTILLA. AS A YOUNG
AFRICAN AMERICAN GROWING UP IN
THE SIXTIES IN THE SEVENTIES. HE
WAS OUR ROLE MODEL HE WAS OUR
BOX OFFICE CHAMPION AND HE DID
IT WOULD TAKE MANY. HE DID IT
WITH GRACE HE DID WAS ONLY
DEVELOPED IT WITH ELOQUENCE. AND
HE SHOWED TO THE WORLD. WHAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR REALLY WERE
ABOUT AND NOT TO DEMEANING
SHUFFLING ROSE THAT HOLLYWOOD
HAD ASKED AFRICAN AMERICANS TO
BETRAY FOR. OVER FORTY FORTY
FIVE YEARS ANNE WAS A DIGNIFIED
GENTLEMAN AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM- BERMAN IN THE BEVERLY
HILLS AREA STATED- HE INSISTED
ON EVERY ROLE THAT HE PLAYED.
THAT HE WOULD HAVE SAY IN THOSE
CONTRACTS OR WHAT HIS DIALOGUE
WOULD BE BUT JUST AS IMPORTANT
WHAT HIS ROOM WARDROBE WOULD BE
HE INSISTED ON WARREN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR SUITS SO EVERY
TIME YOU SAW MISTER FORTY EIGHT
IN A MOVIE. HE WAS ONE OF
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS SUIT
THAT TODAY WOULD PROBABLY BE
CLOSE TO A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
SUIT AND ALL THE MOVIES TO THIS-
STUDIOS AGREE WENT ON BECAUSE HE
WAS THE BIGGEST BOX OFFICE DRAW.
AT THAT TIME AND HE A EXTREME-
NEGOTIATING RIGHTS BECAUSE THEY
KNEW HOW POWERFUL HE WAS AS FAR
AS A BOXOFFICE DRAW WAS
CONCERNED. AND AS STATED. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN. HE DID
THROUGH THE MOST POWERFUL MOVIES
NOT FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS BUT
FOR ALL AMERICANS AND THAT IS
GUESS WHO'S COMING TO DINNER TO
SIR WITH LOVE IN THE HEAT OF THE
NIGHT ONE OF THE CONDITIONS ON
THE HEAT OF THE NIGHT WAS IN
FEMININE PIECES I WILL NOT GO
DOWN SOUTH OF THE MASON DIXON
LINE BECAUSE OF WHAT HAD BEEN
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE WHO
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT HE HAD
BEEN SHOT AT. HE AND HARRY
BELAFONTE AND HE INSISTED THAT
HE WOULD NOT. GOAL SOUTH OF THE
MASON DIXON LINE SO. THE TOWN OF
SEPARATE- SUPPORTER I SHOULD SAY
DAX IN THE MOVIE THIS IS PART OF
MISSISSIPPI IT'S REALLY FAILED
IN ILLINOIS' AND- THE FILM THAT
IN ILLINOIS' BUT IT CAME TO A
POINT IN THE MOVIE WHERE THEY
DID NEED TO GO SOUTH. BECAUSE
THEY NEEDED A SCENE IN THE
COTTON FIELDS. AND BAY
NEGOTIATED AND STUDY GOING TO
MISSISSIPPI THEY WANT TO
TENNESSEE- BUT IN GOING TO
TENNESSEE THEY MADE SURE MR
BELAFONTE WAS WELL PROTECTED. AT
ALL SECURITY THAT HE NEEDED AND
EVEN THE- PRODUCER AND THE
DIRECTOR SAID. I WILL PROTECT
YOU. I'M SORRY THAT. BUT I THINK
IT'S MOST IMPORTANT ROLE PEOPLE
FILLED UNDERSTAND IS THAT. HE
PRETTY MUCH. HELPED BANKROLL THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. IN THE
FIFTIES AND THE SIXTIES THIS MAN
PUT HIS CAREER AND HIS LIFE ON
THE LINE TO STAND WITH DR KING.
AND STAND WITH ALL THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT- LEADERS OF THAT
TIME. IF YOU CAN SEE AND MANY OF
THE MAJOR EVENTS IS A MARCH ON
WASHINGTON YOU NAME IT. HARRY
BELAFONTE SYDNEY PORTILLA A-
SAMMY DAVIS JUNIOR. THEY WERE
THERE. AND CITY CITY PARTY A WAS
THE REASON WHY MANY OF THEM
SHOWED UP JACKIE ROBINSON
BECAUSE HE WAS THE FIRST TO SAY
THAT IN AS- MY COLLEAGUE STATED
HE WAS A MAN WITH LIMITED
EDUCATION. HE DROPPED OUT OF
SCHOOL AT THE AGE OF THIRTEEN
WITH ONLY A YEAR AND A HALF OF
FORMAL EDUCATION. BUT HE WAS
PROBABLY THE ONE MOST ELOQUENT
SPEAKERS EVER- ONE OF THE MOST
ARTICULATE AND- ONE OF THE MOST
DIGNIFIED AND HUMBLE. AND I
REMEMBER THE OPPORTUNITY I HAD
TO MEET MISTER BROWN- PORTILLA.
AND EVERYBODY'S RUNNING AROUND.
PERMISSION AROUND AT THE AREAS
SAID NORMAN A CORNER IN THE
BACKYARD ALL BY HIMSELF THIS
UNASSUMING WAS A BIG EVENT FOR
BARACK OBAMA AND I MADE MY WAY
OVER THERE AND HE WAS IS
GRACIOUS AND KIND. AND I'LL
NEVER FORGET IT AND HE WAS A
HUMBLE SPIRIT SO I'M JUST WANT
TO STAND HERE AND PRECIADO ALL
THAT MR BELAFONTE DID NOT ONLY.
AS AN ACTOR BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
AS HUMAN MANDATARIO AS A
INDIVIDUAL WHO STOOD UP FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS FOR ALL PEOPLE OF
ALL COLORS. AND HIS LEGACY WILL
LIVE ON THE FAR BEYOND THE
SILVER SCREEN BUT WHAT HE DID
AND FELT TO MENTION ALSO. TEN
YEARS AS THE U. S. I MEAN-
BAHAMIAN- AMBASSADOR TO JAPAN.
NOW A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T KNOW
THAT HE WAS IT AND- **** TO
JAPAN REPRESENTING THE BAHAMAS
FOR TEN YEARS SO. HE WAS A
DIPLOMAT- A LEGACY OF A MOVIE
STAR BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY JUST.
HUMBLE AND KIND INDIVIDUAL SO I
SAID WE'D GERMAN AND MEMMIUS.
MISS SYDNEY PORTILLA. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD CENTERS BE SURE
HIS NAME IS FOR A FOUR SO CAN BE
PROBABLY MEMORIALIZED AT
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. MEMBERS
WE'RE RETURNING TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR SENATOR WIENER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. BUT. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS- TO EXPRESS OUR
COMMUNITIES HORROR DISCUSSED AND
FEAR REGARDING THE ATTACK ON
CONGREGATION BETH ISRAEL AND
COLLEYVILLE TEXAS. ANTISEMITISM
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS THE
OLDEST TEACHER IT REARED ITS
UGLY AND DESTRUCTIVE IN VICIOUS
HAD YET AGAIN ON SATURDAY. I
THINK THERE ARE TWO IMPORTANT
THINGS TO NOTE HERE. ONE WHICH
IS SURPRISING AND ONE WHICH IS
NOT. THE FIRST THE PART THAT'S
NOT SURPRISING. THAT THE WAY
THAT THE ATTACKER GOT INTO THE
SYNAGOGUE. WAS BECAUSE THE RABBI
INVITED HIM AND BECAUSE HE
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS IN DISTRESS
AND IN NEED. THE RABBI SHOWED
WILL RECALL TO CRIMINAL LAW I'M
HEALING THE WORLD WHICH IS A
CORE PILLAR OF JUDAISM. THAT WE
MUST BE THERE FOR OUR FELLOW
HUMAN BEINGS. AND THE ROB I
INVITED HIM AND EVEN THOUGH HE
WAS A PERSON WHO WAS POTENTIALLY
GOING TO KILL THE RABBI AND
MEMBERS OF HIS CONGREGATION. THE
PART THAT IS SURPRISING IS THE
WAY THAT THIS ENDED YES THANK
YOU TO LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR BEING
THERE AND FOR PRIORITIZING. OUR
COMMUNITY. IT ENDED BECAUSE THE
RABBI AND ONE OF THE CONGREGANTS
HAD SECURITY TRAINING. AND SO
THEY WERE ABLE TO FREE
THEMSELVES AND ESCAPE BEFORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ONE N. THAT'S GREAT.
THAT'S FANTASTIC ALL WE SAVE
LIVES BUT YOU MIGHT ASK YOURSELF
. WHY DID ARRIVE I HAVE SECURITY
TRAINING. RABBIS ARE MANY FAMOUS
FRIENDS TEACHERS SPIRITUAL
ADVISERS. MANY MANY THINGS
SECURITY EXPERTS IS NOT PROBABLY
THE FIRST THING THAT COMES TO
MIND WHEN YOU THINK OF A RABBI.
THE REASON THIS RABBI AND ONE OF
THE CONGREGANTS HAD SECURITY
TRAINING. THAT'S BECAUSE IN THIS
MODERN WORLD OF OURS. THAT
TRAINING IS NOW ESSENTIAL FOR
JEWISH INSTITUTIONS IT'S NOT
OPTIONAL. IT'S ESSENTIAL. AND
WHEN YOU GO TO SYNAGOGUE AND
HAVE TO WALK THROUGH A METAL
DETECTOR. IN SAN FRANCISCO OR IN
OTHER PARTS OF THIS COUNTRY
AROUND THE WORLD. YOU SEE THAT
FIRST HAND. BECAUSE THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY. CONTINUES TO BE UNDER
ATTACK HERE IN THIS COUNTRY. AND
AROUND THE WORLD. SYNAGOGUES
JEWISH COMMUNITY CENTERS RICHARD
GROCERY STORES JEWISH DAY
SCHOOLS ALL OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS ARE UNDER THREAT
AND HAVE BEEN ATTACKED NINETY
TEN YOU TO BE ATTACKED. THIS HAY
AND THE VIOLENCE IS NOT NEW IT
IS THOUSANDS OF YEARS OLD THAT'S
WHY IT IS SOMETIMES REFERRED TO.
AS THE OLDEST HATRED. AND IT IS
STILL WITH US. OUR COMMUNITY IS
STILL BEING SYSTEMATICALLY
TARGETED. WITH VIOLENCE. WE ONLY
HAVE TO LOOK AT IT HISTORY GOING
THROUGH TODAY TO SEE WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR JEWS THROUGHOUT
HISTORY OUR COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
EXPELLED FROM COUNTRY AFTER
COUNTRY AFTER COUNTRY WE'VE BEEN
SUBJECT TO FORCED CONVERSIONS.
WE CAN BLAME FOR PANDEMICS
WHETHER IT'S THE BUBONIC PLAGUE
IN THE MIDDLE EAST AS WE WERE
BLAMED FOR THAT WORKOVER
NINETEEN. WE'VE BEEN SUBJECT TO
PERON'S THE DESTRUCTION OF
ENTIRE VILLAGES IN EASTERN
EUROPE THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY MY FAMILY. CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY AND I IMAGINE OTHER
FAMILIES OF THE JEWISH MEMBERS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE. SUBJECT TO
MASSACRES FORCED RELOCATION INTO
GHETTOS OF THAT HAS HAPPENED
THROUGHOUT HISTORY GENOCIDE. AND
THE TARGETING OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS WITH VIOLENCE. WITH
SWASTIKAS AND WITH OTHER
VANDALISM WE SEE IT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. CONSTANTLY ANTI SEMITISM
JUST CASUAL ANTISEMITISM ON
SOCIAL MEDIA WE SEE IN OUR
POLITICS TODAY IN THIS COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE WORLD. WHERE
PEOPLE WHO ARE RUNNING FOR
OFFICER INVOLVED IN THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM FEEL LIBERATED
TO ATTACK JEWS. COLLEAGUES IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WE PASSED A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
CALIFORNIA'S SECURITY NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM BUT I
WANT TO THANK MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY AND THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR MAKING THAT HAPPEN
WE INCREASED AT THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT IS IT
DOES A LIFESAVING DOLLARS FOR
SYNAGOGUES OR CHURCHES AND
MOSQUES FOR COMMUNITY CENTERS
AND SO FORTH. BUT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT EVEN THOUGH OUR JEWISH
CAUCUS IS COMPLETELY COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING. TO EXPAND AND TO
RENEW THAT PART OF MONIES THAT
ARE COMMUNITIES INSTITUTIONS AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES INSTITUTIONS.
ARE SAFE. BUT I HAVE TO SAY IT
IS DEEPLY TRAGIC FOR OUR
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO BE WORKING ON IT IS SO
TRAGIC THAT THE TOP PRIORITY FOR
OUR CAUCUS EVERY YEAR. IS
FUNDING NONPROFIT SECURITY
GRANTS OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY WANTS TO
WORK ON AND NEEDS TO WORK ON
SUPPORTING CHILDREN SENIORS
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS
FOOD ON THE TABLE. MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE THE HOMELESSNESS OF
ALL THE THINGS THAT RISES TO THE
TOP WIDE. BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITY
IS LITERALLY UNDER PHYSICAL
DURESS. IT'S A TRAGEDY BUT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO THAT WORK. I
WANT TO THANK MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY WHO'VE BEEN SO SUPPORTIVE
OF OUR COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
THE ATTACKS ON OUR COMMUNITY.
ANTISEMITISM MAY BE THE OLDEST
HATRED. BUT NOTHING LASTS
FOREVER. AND WE NEED TO ALL
RECOMMIT TO ENDING AT ONCE AND
FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS INTERACTIONS THE DOSES
CLEAR MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU ALL
AND THE OUR NEXT FOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AT NINE AM. MEMBERS THE
SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED. WE
WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE
AM WE STAND ADJOURNED.